foreign
Montreal lineup Suzuki along with Caufield and
new hook starting up front and here's Morgan Riley
playing his second preseason game for Toronto
around the boards and Alex Steves got straightened
up brought back up by New Hope acquired for a
first a second of a prospect at last year's draft
with the Colorado Avalanche here's full copy of
winding in Caulfield spins and shoots it's off
the outside of the goal Suzuki far end of note
also today Montreal from 30 Guys released from
their roster down to Laval go back to Junior or
on waivers Ary without Christians with the loss
to them here's Steve's with it Alex Steves was
attacking the corner Barrel goes back treasurement
wins that battle for the puck rapper on dry score
Matthew nice does it again one nothing Toronto
and there's Minton and nice working their
magic again pretty much all the last couple
games and loose puck [Applause] Minton
draws two and that's not a good goal for
San Manzo ball again it's a tight
wrap around nice get there quickly
lone defensive Zone coverage but he does not get
his foot against the post montamo and nice just
beats him to it that's not supposed to go in but
nice continues with hot streak two in a row here
I did that one time with the Toronto Maple Leafs
down to the Dome yeah how was your swim uh I was
much more like Mitch Martin than I was like Steve
Madden says this swing is terrible so yeah okay
that was the uh Tony Gwynn of body practice
a lot of opposite Field contact high on base
percentage you can start the second period five
on five here's reinbacher with it found a new
look a shot that the flex wide and Suzuki
back with it the point he goes to ghouli
Hayden ghouli drops it back for Suzuki
a little race shot got through Jones
to say rebound loose in front New Look
jamming at a Caulfield from a sharp angle
that's knocked Away by Jones new hook back
forces Julie tease it up and rips that way
doing a big offensive defensive
in the Western Hockey League
new hook swings it back for reinbacher who
jumped up Suzuki tell us a coffee they're
a little bit careless and comes Traeger
across the line from into down to Gregor
Vincent Watson shoots and Lonzo got a
tip of the glove on that to knock it away
for Steves after Azizi centers it didn't
get a shot away now Suzuki races to it
the Suzuki poke jumped there by Gregor
abruz easy for Steve's walking in he's at
a cross score Minton on the power play makes it
two-nothing Toronto Fraser Minton continues his
strong preseason going forward thinking Suzuki
had the inside position but Gregor turns it over
with an excellent stick and then Steve sells the
shot he knew he was going to pass it the second
he got it kicks it over to Minton but that play
to turn it over keep it alive and Minden finds
a way to get it through multiple he knows it's
coming over he just can't go far enough to get
there in time and you're right Fraser Renton
what a camp he's having cleaned up by TJ Brody
he's got Clifford with him Easton Cowan blocks
it in shoots short side stop there by bonzabo
offset back to Anderson CS Anderson
winds in shoveled Away by Jones
now for Homer and short-handed he's got
Gregor with him Holmberg trigger that
wide a great look there for Noah Gregor
shorthand brought back by new hook along
with Liz Anderson new hook to Anderson
takes it back across not clear by reply
walks in and shoots I was blocked by revive
20 seconds to go in the Montreal power play
to go move back across lavkoski
and shoots Buck by revive
final seconds of this power play ski winds
that back to Trudeau's up and shoots in that
deflected Robertson rockets on The Penalty Box in
comes Nick Robertson walking in and shoot scores
he got that one and Nick Robertson didn't like
the call but liked the result he lies you're out
of the box Trudeau did not start skating until
Robertson had the angle and that's a nice move
taken to the far side and finishing him but
look at Trudeau he's tired he doesn't really
dig in because he thinks he has time to go get
it defense is going to let him know he's got a
not best schools in Ohio oh it says the product of
Bowling Green State University Midwest
yes new hook wins that away from Minton
drop set back to New hook shoots off
the pipe as Jones waved it back now
for slavkoski back to to know her
new hook in shoots a puck on the
cave rebound put on goal but Sean
Farrell turned away down it goes
[Applause]
and then going the other way Suzuki knew he had
momentum to challenge Cowan so Cowan collects
to go with a quick shot tries to sneak it through
and how's your first shot yeah [Music] [Applause]
Jones up to hang on to that he thought about
dropping it and knocking it up to nice because
ghoulie was activating on the back door
and Jones having himself a night might
not try to mix in an assist with a strong
evening set it up to the players on a break
engine with a Face-Off against Zoo
hooker wins that cleanly back to kova7
what kind of charm that time and Kaden Cooley
has the short-handed goal to get Montreal on
the board Maxim rotation and Matthew nice is
thinking about a one-timer and he just gets
caught watching the puck Cooley activating
because they're down three nothing he's got
nothing to lose jumps in behind but how about
the backhand pass reception clean quick snipe
and that is an excellent release that's the
goal scorer from a defenseman who scored a bunches
3-19 the shots on goal in favor of the Canadians
shoots he fires that wide sharp
angle linebacker put it high and one
Becker steps up again Wolford stepped
hard into him down by Harvey Bernard
picked up by doc with that line a little
race with a [__] scooped up by Turbo
opposite back to Clifford
backwardsburg to put that wide
and Turbo's right away from Richmond Hill
Ontario has a Swedish Stephanie name but he's
going to play college hockey
to move to Connecticut slaven
made the same rebound and slaven turned
away by Dobby now Brody backs up and
plays it across the Cowan Cowan Brown
Farrell as we spin that back Helen's
still with it moves in and shoots
and dobach makes a good stop on him
up to Sunrise Suzuki knocks that
down moving in O'Reilly Caulfield
joins the attack it's as if he plays
around but it's picked off by Brody
picked up S Jones makes it stop right now
you want to do a good job with it but if you
feel great that he's trusting you In This
Moment face off one by new hook Caulfield
cleans it down to dock trying to Center but pass
is blocked by Riley and now the Olympus shot was
blocked by nice and the puck back to Center
Ice the timeline down here in the third period
and Toronto will sweep the two
games in this series in Montreal
as they take this one by a final score of three to
one three second round picks scoring for Toronto